there are about 200 museums and
memorials in Berlin some are on
everyone's must-see list others are less
well known the noise museum is one of
five showcase buildings located on
museum Island some of the exhibits date
back to the dawn of history
the number one attraction is without a
doubt the bust of the Egyptian Queen
Nefertiti which dates back to the 14th
century BC those interested in Cold War
history should visit checkpoint charlie
a former crossing point in the berlin
wall
the museum there features exhibits on
successful escape attempts from East
Germany to the West
this museum is incredibly interesting
not only does it give the history of
checkpoint charlie and the way people
escape which I thought that's all it
would have he gave the history of the
Berlin wall and a lot of the information
about the GDR the DDR museum features
hands-on exhibits on life in the former
East Germany the GDR you can even steer
a tubby through rows of prefabricated
housing blocks
when it's time for a little
fortification you can find a curry boss
stand on just about every corner those
who wish to learn more about this Berlin
delicacy can stop by the curly blues
Museum
there's even an aroma test for the sauce
ingredients
at the Bauhaus archive you'll find bag
and Fez lamps and other objects created
by influential Bauhaus designers and
architects The Ramones museum pays
tribute to the founding fathers of punk
rock the museum's founder Florian hila
has assembled private photos autographed
posters and articles of the band's
clothing welcome Berlin makeup artistry
Nico has created a private museum
devoted to lipstick there are hundreds
of exhibits photos and artworks to
picked lipstick through the ages from
ancient Egypt to early Japan
the topography of Terror Memorial Museum
is built on the site of the former
Gestapo headquarters it deals with the
history of the Third Reich and the
horrific crimes committed by the Nazis
throughout Europe this museum keeps
history alive it reminds people what
happened I think that's really good
concession nearly 1 million people visit
the topography of Terror documentation
center every year